gpt 3 learns to edit text text to image
generators achieve new heights and
google finally introduces their pathway
system welcome to ml news
[Music]
quick word from our sponsor weights and
biases if you don't know weights and
biases you should definitely check them
out they are the best when it comes to
ml ops it's the entire package they will
automatically track your experiments
send everything to the cloud track your
models your outputs you can even give
them your data sets they tune your hyper
parameters they make everything
shareable with your team and with the
wider world is really cool today i want
to highlight this report that i found by
scott condren so it's a little bit of a
showcase what you can do in a wonderb
report and what he's showing here is
sort of a before picture where people
took screenshots of tensorboard log
plots or even matplotlib plots now he
made it a bit pixelish on purpose but
i've definitely seen things like this in
papers crazy but no more with weights
and biases reports you can share your
research with the highest quality
available so let's say you've tracked a
bunch of experiments and you want to
present the best ones people can check
them out interactively you see right
here i can go i can zoom in i can click
on a run i can inspect that run in
detail like what were its hyper
parameters how much cpu and ram did it
use what was the console log output of
that run everything is observable but
not only that let's say i want to
communicate how different hyper
parameters affect the final objective
well the best way to do this is a plot
like this this shows me all the runs in
different hyper parameter configurations
on each of these axes and where they end
up in the final loss again this is fully
interactive and you as the writer of the
report can place it wherever you want
but it's not only about experiments
reports can also include 1db tables and
tables are really cool tables are like
an excel sheet on steroids and again
this is fully interactive i can inspect
any cell here so you can even
interactively modify these tables so
i've actually introduced a column in
this other person's report that shows me
whenever the ground truth label doesn't
agree with the model and i'm able to
sort by this and explore wherever the
model makes mistakes this is really neat
because it decouples who runs the
experiments and the evaluations from who
does the analysis on the data so this is
just a small set of features that you
can do in reports and they work
especially well within teams or
collaborators worldwide again i invite
you to check out weights and biases
they've been really great sponsor go to
wandabee.me yannick to let them know i
sent you and now let's get into the
video
[Music]
all right hello everyone it's monday and
a new episode of ml news wide-angle
camera really nice you see more of me i
don't know if that's a good thing gpt-3
gains new editing capabilities so if you
don't know gpt3 is a language model by
openai it's been available through their
api you can go to it you can ask it to
produce text and code and now they've
added a new feature that allows you to
actually edit text and code they have a
bunch of demos right here where they
write a piece of code and then ask the
model to change it in some way for
example to make the fibonacci
computation use memorization and then
interestingly to translate it from
python to javascript which is quite
impressive now as i said this doesn't
only work for code it also works for
text and i just thought we'd give it a
try all right so i'm here in the open ai
api and what i can do is i want to go
and select the codex edit model you can
see right here you have different modes
there's the complete mode which gives
you the traditional models there is the
insert mode which gives you the new
insert capabilities and the edit mode
again with the edit capabilities all
right so let's come up with a simple
function
cool so now that i have this i can
instruct the model to do all kinds of
things so here in the instructions i'll
say
make a doc string
this is a docs
well okay we might have been oversold a
little bit let's try let's try a bit
more generate this function's docs
string this function squares its
argument excellent nice add parameter
information to the docs string
nice
all right we're getting somewhere add
type hints
look at that ah here there's a button
used as input
i'm done all right now let's try this
translate to javascript
boom docstring's been translated
function's been translated excellent
yeah i can definitely see how this is
powerful let's try another one
okay this is a short recursive
implementation of a depth first tree
search now it does have some tricky bits
for example we're using implicit return
value of none in python and we're never
telling it what the type of node is we
just make it have some properties that
are implicitly assumed so let's see if
it gets what this is generate an
accurate docs string
add a doc string to the dfs function
nice okay let's see if it gets the types
add type hints
okay very cool all right now the super
challenge translate dfs from a recursive
to an iterative
algorithm
yep
that's it very very nice okay there's
one thing that i always wanted to do but
it's not in edit mode
okay checks if the program halts return
not halt's programmable
i guess the ancient computer scientists
would be happy with that answer cool
remember the openai api after a long
time of being closed beta waiting list
what not is now available for access to
everyone so if you want you can go play
with this stuff
there's a new paper out of meta called
make a scene scene scene-based
text-to-image generation with human
priors now this pushes the state of the
art in image generation from text so
here are a bunch of examples for example
the painting of blue elephant or a teddy
bear with blue scarves and eyes tilted
to its left like these are really
accurate and really high quality
productions now there is a bit of a
difference between something like this
and dali or glide which is that this
takes a number of auxiliary inputs for
example it can take a segmentation map
which you can see here in the middle of
the generated images it can also take
reference images from which it will copy
over the visual tokens so there's more
information provided to the model but in
return you get a lot better quality
output now one cool output of this is
the illustration of a story that the
authors made and put on youtube so the
story is called the little red boat and
all the images are illustrated by this
model the little red boat woke up near
the shore one day where are all his
friends he couldn't say he decided to
set sail to the open sea to find out
where everyone could be so the story in
itself is pretty neat and i think it
gives a nice outlook on the near future
we can expect out of these models like
since i've made my music video we've
come such a long way and that's not too
far back so the progress in this field
is absolutely astounding
so finally the pathways paper is out
google has talked about this in a blog
post before by jeff dean and we've
reported on that but as of that point it
wasn't really clear what pathways was i
was more under the impression that it is
kind of a new model architecture where
google wants to build like these giant
models that have multi-task components
and you would only update them sparsely
and so on however this paper right here
describes more of like an infrastructure
side of things now i don't know but
given that it's called the same and it
is it's come out of the same company i'm
pretty sure that you know this is
actually what they meant hi this is
yannick during editing and jeff dean has
just posted a tweet that says this paper
is about the pathway system that is
designed to support the broader pathways
vision of creating large-scale
multi-task multiple models with flexible
support yada yada so it appears that
even though the paper is called exactly
the same as the vision the two are
separate things and one is in service of
the other back to the video so what is
pathways the best way i can describe it
is something like mapreduce for machine
learning so imagine you have all these
data centers and you have all these
accelerators around and some are
connected with super fast infiniband and
some are connected with a network
latency what pathways allows you to do
is to super efficiently distribute your
computation across any number of devices
and in a heterogeneous way so while
we've become pretty good at something
like single instruction multiple data
computation where we simply distribute
data to different accelerators and then
run the exact same thing on all of them
until we synchronize them again
heterogeneous computation is a little
bit more tricky so if i want something
to happen on one part of the data but
then something else on a different part
like that's a problem especially if the
things take different amounts of time
then one is idling and so on pathways is
essentially a very very smart compiler
and scheduler to distribute computation
across whatever now i'm not
knowledgeable enough in hardware and the
interconnect between how you trace your
functions in your ml programs how the
xla compiler then figures out how long
everything takes and then asynchronously
schedules everything in parallel to
absolutely optimize your throughput but
this is essentially what's happening
right here i invite you to read the
pathways paper because it is very
detailed and gives you good overview
over what's to come in the future now
presumably google is going to deploy
these things in their own data centers
which either means that you can expect
faster ml workflows on gcp maybe the
prices will come down or maybe they'll
just make more profit anything could
happen
doe blind is a social peer review
platform this is a website where anyone
can go and review any paper so this is
an open platform you can make an account
you can search for a paper you can see
what reviews already exist and you can
post your own reviews and this can
happen in a personalized or in an
anonymous fashion now they've already
indexed as far as i can see most of the
machine learning papers but most of them
obviously don't have any reviews yet so
i've searched for myself right here and
i agree with the 0 out of five star
rating although i think they should have
like one like one is generous but there
you see the problems with these types of
platforms now while i definitely agree
that something like this would be super
valuable with all the problems that come
along you know anyone can come here and
post a review and have bad intentions
and smear other people's work and blah
blah blah but with all of that i still
think it's a valuable addition however
this only works if really the whole
community decides to make this the hub
of things and i just don't see that
happening in the near future anytime
soon wait that's a tautology the near
future anytime soon like that's the same
all right so i'm definitely excited to
see what happens with these platforms
this is not the only one but it seems
pretty cool i have not yet seen any
incentive here to cash in somehow on
this which makes me a bit more hopeful
for this one but what i'd really like to
see is this being connected to something
like archive directly so that i don't
have to go to this website to get my
reviews but just the reviews somehow get
aggregated from the whole internet to
this platform so when i write something
about the paper on twitter then it might
be aggregated here too and therefore you
don't force the people onto a platform
but you simply grab what's out there
about particular papers now we've seen
previously that something like zetta
alpha tries to do this automatically but
there again that's a different business
model so we'll see what happens in the
future i can't tell but i do welcome
good intended efforts to revamp the peer
review system
this is an interesting paper clip meets
game physics so this is a pretty simple
method to use clip to find bugs in video
games so people often upload buggy
footage of video games to reddit and i'm
i'm sorry that that is that is a bit but
like what did you do to that horse
so
video game developers might want to
structurally search through all of these
videos that ow that are played and
uploaded uh from people who find these
types of bugs and this is exactly what
this paper does so so they take all of
these videos they index them using clip
and then you're able to search for them
for example if you search for a person
flying in the air in the grand theft
auto 5 database you'll get all kinds of
buggy clips of things that maybe should
or maybe shouldn't be happening now this
is a great help probably to game
developers but it does have a downside
namely you can only search for the bugs
that you know exist so this was actually
a legitimate person flying in the air
like i'm pretty sure that's what should
happen but let's say a user comes to you
and says well all of a sudden my
character was stuck in the air or stuck
in a tree or stuck in a wall what you
could do is you could turn on the search
engine and you could search through all
of the footage of all of the people who
played this game whether or not
something like this was happening
somewhere else now the usefulness of
this obviously goes beyond video games
you could search any type of image or
video footage through that there are
some shortcomings as i said you can only
search for things that you know and also
right now this is simply implemented as
taking a bunch of frames and then
running them through clip and searching
across them so you're not able to
necessarily search anything that happens
in a temporal fashion in the video it's
not a true video search it's more like a
frame search that all being said pretty
cool project the data set is released so
you can try it out for yourself
another paper that has caught my
attention is auto-aggressive image
generation using residual quantization
by cacao brain and pos tech this is
another paper that pushes the state of
the art in image generation from text so
the samples you see here are pretty neat
and they can be generated not only from
text but also conditionally for example
the top two pictures are conditioned on
imagenet classes the bottom two pictures
are produced from a text prompt and the
core of this paper revolves around a
technique called residual quantization
now usually if you do vector
quantization what you want to do is you
want to run your image through some sort
of a down sampler some sort of a feature
extractor like a convnet or a
transformer and then at the end of that
you quantize it into individual chunks
individual visual tokens what this model
does is as it down samples the image in
the feature extractor it quantizes at
each stage and then it remembers the
residual of what it quantized so it will
end up with a multi-scale representation
essentially of visual token plus
whatever is needed to reconstruct the
finer grained stage that came before it
so this can retain potentially a lot
more information about the fine-grained
structure of the image and enables these
really high quality productions now
what's also cool is that the models are
available specifically there is a
3.9 billion parameter model available
just for you to download now how you're
gonna run it is a different question but
it is available
[Music]
all right let's get into some helpful
things for this week stumpy is a
powerful and scalable library for time
series data mining fast treeshap is a
package that provides algorithm for
explainability in tree based algorithms
meaning random forest xgboos light gbm
and so on yes there exists something
else than deep learning imagine that
jack stone is a collection of 100 jax
exercises if you've ever wanted to learn
jax this might be the place nov grid is
a variant of mini grid which allows you
to change underlying world dynamics for
example right here the fact that the
yellow key opens the door is exchanged
at test time with the fact that the blue
key opens the door the challenge for the
agents is obviously to adjust to these
new facts at inference time which is
really hard if you've never trained on
them bisect gym is a part of nvidia's
omniverse project this is an engine to
run physics simulations for the purposes
of things like reinforcement learning
population based learning and so on the
main focus here is scale you can run
thousands of these experiments in
parallel if you have an nvidia gpu but
still for the fact that these are
physically accurate simulations it's
pretty cool on github they also have a
repository with a bunch of benchmark
environments for isac gym everything's
available to download check it out and
this was already it for ml news this
week it's been a bit of a slow week but
i hope you still had fun if you like
slow weeks please subscribe one
subscriber equals one pathway at the
google data center until then see you
next time
[Music]